[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو ان السلام بين بلاده ومصر
يستند الى ترتيبات امنيه متينه مضيفا ان
التطورات في المنطقه تدل على ان السيطره
على ما سماه الاسلام المتطرف ليست مستحيله
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
مسار العلاقات المصريه الاسرائيليه منذ
ثوره يناير
والى ما بعد الانقلاب على الرئيس محمد
مرسي
مدى تاثير العلاقه مع اسرائيل على الواقع
السياسي المصري وعلى علاقات القاهره
الخارجيه
[موسيقى]
تخلت اسرائيل عن الحذر في تناول الشان
المصري في الشهور الاخيره وقد اعتبر
الرئيس حكومتها بنيامين نتنياهو عزل
الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي دليلا على ضعف
الحركات الاسلاميه وفي كلمه امام الكينيست
اشار نتنياهو الى ان هناك شعوب عديده في
المنطقه لديها رغبه في نبذ ما سماه التشدد
في ايران وحكم الاخوان وتنظيم القاعده وهو
ما اعتبره تطورا اذا دلاله تاريخيه ووصف
نتنياهو السلامه بين تل ابيب والقاهره
بانه مرساه للاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط
وقال ان الجميع يدرك اهميه هذه المساله
ليس كل ما يعرف يقال هنا وعلى الملا تلك
هي وصيه نتنياهو بل اوامره لاركان حكومته
في اكثر من ملف ومن بينها المصري لكن ثمه
ما قاله اخيرا ومنه ان السلام مع مصر صمام
امان الاستقرار في المنطقه وان المخاوف من
وصول الاسلاميين الى الحكم ليست حكرا على
الحكومات العربيه وبشكل واضح لا لبس فيه
قال الرجل ان النشوه التي اجتاحت المنطقه
قبل عامين بسبب ال وصول الاسلاميين او ما
يسميه الاسلام الراديكاليه لم تخدعه انذاك
ولا اليوم ف مخاوفه ظلت على ما هي عليه
بدايه التزام الحذر عند ما ادى مرسى
اليمين بعد ذلك تعاون الجانبان ل تثبيت
الهدنه بين اسرائيل وحماس لينتهي الامر
الى فرح في تل ابيب لم تستطع النخب
الاسرائيليه اخفائه عندما اعلن الفريق عبد
الفتاح السيسي الاطاحه بمرسي ووصل الامر
بنات مياه حد ارسال وفد رفيع الى واشنطن
لمؤازره حكام مصر الجدد
بينما قامت المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه
بما هو اكثر وهو السماح للجيش المصري
بحريه اكبر في سيناء لملاحقه منتصفه
القاهره وتل ابيب بالارهاب في دفاع مؤيدي
السيسي عن كل ذلك يقولون ان اولويه
اللي هي استعاده مصر واعاده الاعتبار
لجيشها وموسى كما يقولون وليس هو من وصف
بيريز بصديقه العظيم في رساله شهيره وهو
اساسي من توسط مع تل ابيب بعد حربها
الاخيره على غزه
من سمحت غول الحركات الجهاديه في سيناء و
استخدمها لصالحه داخليا اما منتقل السياسي
فيرون بان التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل
تجاوز حقبه مبارك برمتها للطرفين كما
يقولون عدو واحد على جانبي الحدود حماس في
غزه والاخوان في مصر وبينها جماعات جهاديه
على الحدود وبعيدا عن قصر المسافه او
طولها بين اي زعيم مصري واسرائيل يبقى
السؤال الاهم هو من هو الطرف الذي تعتبره
اسرائيل الاكثر قدره على توفير امنها
وراحت بالها
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا في
الاستوديو حاتم عزام نائب رئيس حزب الوسط
والمنسق العام لجبهه الضمير ايضا مع ضيفنا
من واشنطن مختار كامل رئيس تحالف المصريين
الامريكيين مع ضيفنا من القدس
استاذ الدراسات السياسيه في جامعه تل ابيب
وعندما يقول العلاقه بين مصر
واسرائيل تستند الى ترتيبات امنيه
متينه
اه طبعا هناك السلام واه لوبان ال اه
البنود ال اه
الامنيه ولكن اه اعتقد بان اه السلام
الاسرائيلي المصري اه السلام يستند الى
مصالح مشتركه
امنيا ولكن كمان مساله في اقتصاديه و اه
سياسيه اه اه ولكن الحقيقه انه اه يعني في
اه ملحق عسكري وهناك
شبه جزيره سيناء
اه خليه من
اه اه مؤسسات او من مركز للجيش المصري اه
كان من البدايه اه في عيون اسرائيل ان ذاك
اه لما وقعت الاتفاق اه شيء اه مهم جدا
ولكن كمان كما اشرت يعني ال ال المساله
ومش بس المساله
الاشكاليه موجوده هناك اه اه يعني مشاكل
فيه ناس امنيه في سيناء موضوع حماس ولكن
ما ممكن نقول موضوع الاستقرار الاستقرار
السياسي
طبعا الاستقرار الاقتصادي
اه يعني اه افتتحت
افتتحت امس جلسه اه اه اه اه اه ال
الكنيسيت اه واه
سيف للكنيسيت وكانت هذه المناسبه لو كان
ليس اي جديد فيما كله نتنياهو هذا ما
يقولون كل المسؤولين الامنيين والسياسيين
في اه اسرائيل منذ البدايه طبعا منذ
ثلاثين يونيو ولكن اه كمان قبل ثلاثين يوم
من ايام حكم محمد موسى اه لم تكن ايام
موسى علاقات مباشره اه على المستوى
السياسي بين موسم وبين اه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ولكن كمان ايام موسى كان هناك
تنسيق امني والمسائل الامنيه والتنسيق
الامني كان
لا جديد يقول لا في كلام
طبيعيه المعاديه اتفاقيه
اه اسمحي لي اقول لحضرتك انه العلاقات ال
ال يعني اه المصريه مع اه اه سلطه
الاحتلال في اسرائيل اه مرت بثلاث مراحل
في الفتره الفتره مع مبارك حينما كانت
تعتبر ان مبارك كنزا استراتيجيا لاسرائيل
وحينما قامت ثوره 25 يناير التزم سلطه
الاحتلال في ال ال الاسرائيلي الصمت اتجاه
ما يمر مصلحه تنتظر ماذا سيحدث لانه صور
كانت مفاجئه للجميع ثم جاءت حاله ايام
الرئيس مرسي وانا اقول لحضرتك معلومه يمكن
اول مره تذاع انه اه طلب او عرض على
الرئيس مرسي ان يلتقي باحد المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين يعني ال ابداء مقترحات على
كامب ديفيد في اسرائيل ولكن الرئيس مرسي
لم يحدث هذه الفكره
والتشاور حولها على تعديلات في في كامب
ديفيد في اسرائيل ولكن الرئيس مرسي لم
يذهب الى نعم حتى التقت لها الصور في
الاساس يعني ولكن الرئيس مشرف هذه معلومه
نقولها على مسؤوليه الشخصيه واعلنا اه اه
الحاجه الثالثه انه بعد الانقلاب العسكري
الحقيقه صحيح ان نتنياهو كان ماكنش ظاهر
في المقدمه ولكن كان هناك دعم من ال ال
سلطه الاحتلال الفلسطيني اللي سلطه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للانقلاب العسكري قبل
الانقلاب وبعد الانقلاب وهذا شهد بتصريحات
اه يعني قاده سلطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نفسها تحدثت في هذا ال ال وزيره الخارجيه
تسيبي ليفني اه في احد محاضراتها بشكل
واضح وموجود ومسجل على الانترنيت ثم
انتقلت مصر بعض الانقلاب العسكري من مرحله
كنز الاسر ال ال الاستراتيجي مصطلح النخبه
السياسيه في اسرائيل وان ان تعاملت معنا
الى فكره البطل ال الاسرائيلي قومي يعني
حينما تصدر الصحف الصحف الاسرائيليه
والسفير الاسرائيلي في مصر يخاطب وزير
الزراعه يقولوا انه اساسي ليس بتر ان مصر
فقط ولكن هو بطل قومي الاسرائيلي وكل
اليهود حول العالم فكان هناك دعم حقيقي
لان احنا ثنيها والسلطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى فتره ما بعد الانقلاب
متمثله في شهر اغسطس يستمر في تحرك ين
الرئاسيه التحرك الاول هو حمله دبلوماسيه
قويه شنها اه او قام بها سلطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اه ونتحرك سفراء في عشر دول
اوروبيه وعالميه ل اه دعم الانقلاب
السياسيين حتى تستقر الاوضاع في مصر وحتى
تعترف فيه الحكومات من اول اه بروكسيل حد
امريكا الحكومه الغرب وكلها الحاجه
الثانيه انه دعا الى الى ال الكونغرس
الامريكي لتبني مشروع اقتصادي جديد حتى
يدعم الانقلاب حتى اقتصاديا
وتنجح هذه الفتره فكل هذا المشروع
الامريكي
ال ال الشهاده الثالث هو اللقاء الشهير
الذي ادراك مع فريد زكريا الاعلام في قناه
حين قال له فريد زكريا يعني هل انتم راضون
طبعا عن اللي حصل في مصر بعد الانقلاب ال
واحنا ندعم الى حدود ونطالب كل العالم بدا
الشعوب الحره بدعم اساسي ثم قال له فريد
زكريا سؤال ذكي جدا حقيقه ايران كله يعني
للعجب اه انه السوريه السعوديه واسرائيل
اه تدعم السيسي و ت تعمل من خلاله
يعني احنا
بنفسنا في المقدمه ولكن انا ندعم من الخلف
و خليني اقول لحضرتك هذا كله مشروع فكره
اه اه ثوره الربيع العربي الذي يريد ان
ياتي بحكومه ديمقراطيه منتخبه تعبر عن
اراده الاستقلال الوطني لدى الشعوب
العربيه
اه م قديش انا معلومات مؤكده بان اسرائيل
عمليه ضغط بينما كويس
عفوا عفوا اه ما عنديش معلومات ها ال
اسرائيل ضغطت فاعلا ولا لا لكن اه اه كلام
ان اسرائيل تؤيد الوضع القائم في مصر ان
هذا كلام معقول ولكن يلاحظ ايضا ان
اسرائيل في نفس الوقت حاولت اثناء حكم ال
اه الرئيس السابق مرسي ايضا ان تقيم
علاقات مع الحكومه المصريه الاسلاميه في
ذلك الوقت
وكانت وجهه نظرها التعامل مع التيار
الاسلامي على المدى القصير وظهر ذلك واضحا
في اه
الوفاق ب او دور القاهره تحت حكم الرئيس
مرسي اه في مساله حماس تسويه الامور بينها
وبين اسرائيل وظهر الرئيس مرسى فى ذلك
الوقت فى كافه وسائل الاعلام الغربيه على
انه رئيس المعتدل استطاع ان يعني اه يحقق
شيئا اه
اسرائيل كانت ترى في الحكم الاخواني او
التيار الاسلامي السياسي في مصر ليس خطرا
على الاجل القريب ولكن خطرا على المستوى
الاستراتيجي
على الاقل البعيد جدا لانها كانت تدرك ان
هناك عداء بين الاسلام السياسي وبين فكره
دوله اسرائيل عموما ولكن هذا لا يعني انه
لم يكن هناك اي احتمال للتعاون التكتيكي
بين الطرفين اه لنتذكر ايضا ان من قام ب
تسويه الاوضاع بين حماس واسرائيل منافسه
ضباط المخابرات المصريه
الذين كانوا يقومون بنفس الوظيفه في ايام
الرئيس المخلوع مبارك ولنتذكر ان الذي كان
يمسك بهذا الملف الفلسطيني هو الراحل عمر
سليمان
ورشه ورشه بهذا المخابرات المصريه خلاصه
الكلام ان اه نعم اه اسرائيل والسعوديه
تدعمان او تؤيد ان فكره وجود حكم عسكري في
مصر ولكن في نفس الوقت اسرائيل والغرب
بالذات اه لم يكون يعني معارضين تماما
لحكم الاخوان اه الا في النهايه حين وجدوا
ان الاخوه الغير قادرين على اداره الامور
في مصر اداره الحكيمه
هل صحيح ان اسرائيل الان تجد نفسها مع
بعلاقات انت قلت ان العلاقات كانت جيده
ولكن هل هي اكثر جوده كان الان مع الحكم
الحالي بما بمعنى ان بعض الخبراء وصلوا
الى حد تشبيها بانها عادت كما كانت في عهد
مبارك مميزه الى هذه الدرجه يعني
كمان اه لم تكون العلاقات كويسه لم تكون
سوريا
واه ثقافيه بس
علاقات محدوده بعد من الاجتماعات بين اه
مبارك
والمسؤولين الاسرائيلي مثلا رفض مبارك
موضوع زياره اه اسرائيل كان هناك تنسيق
امني كان هو الاساس ايام
وقال انه اه يعني انت كنت فضل اسرائيل ان
تبقى العلاقات كما هي ايام مباركه ان
تتوتر من حكم الاخوان والاسلام السياسي
والدليل ما قاله نتنياهو في الكنيست
بالامس والان يبدو اكثر ارتياحا بعد ان في
هذا الحكم بعد الراحل هذا الحكم
نعم بدون بدون اي شك يعني ايام يوم محمد
موسى الى
استمرت وكان التنسيق عملي ولكن ال الخط
وكان هناك على المستوى اه اه سياسي كان
هناك رئيس مصري اه كان لا واكيد اه
معارضه لل لاسرائيل طبعا المستوى التكتيكي
اه طبعا بالصوره في ليا استمر
بالعيد استملاكات اللي ولكن ولكن نوصل لم
يكن صديق
لاسرائيل اليوم شكرا اليك الذين يقودون
مصر
ساعود اليك ان اتوقف مع فاصل قصير نناقش
بعده مدى تاثير العلاقه مع اسرائيل على
الواقع السياسي المصري وعلى علاقات
القاهره الخارجيه ان تبقى معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش في تصريح رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بان السلامه بين بلاده ومصر يستند الى
ترتيبات امنيه متينه حتى عزام
كان لديك تعليق على ما
بيقول انه اه لا هناك اه يعني دكتور كامل
كانت تحدث على انه هو يعني هو بيقول ان في
دعم خاص لل اه لل سلطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي السعوديه لكن هو ليس عندهم على
احب يعني اه اولا حضرتك والاستاذ
المشاهدين الاستاذ مختار كامل انه كانت
هناك حمله اه اه قبل الانقلاب قادتها اه
مؤسسات صناع القرار في ال اسرائيل وانا اه
اه اه حضرته والاستاذ المشاهدين الى
الخطبه
تسيبي ليفني في معهد الدراسات الامن
القومي في 17 نوفمبر 2012 عن اهميه التحرك
ضد نظام اه اه مرسي وارد وغير في تركيا
وقال لهم خارجه عن الخط المرسول لهم او
تجاوز الحدود وس يعاني بسبب اما الامر
الاخر هو بخصوص الحمله المرشح اللي انا
تحدثت عنها واحد الم ارشاديه هناك يعني في
الصحافه من صور اسامي اه نواب اه اه واضحه
انه اه يعني اه تم التعامل معهم من
نتانياهو شخصين والتحاور معهم في الكونغرس
الامريكي اعتقد احدهم ونواب كلهم
الجمهوريين انا حكيت حضرتك اسمائهم ولكن
تحدثوا بصراحه على خطه مارشال اه اه
اقترحها ال ال اه اه يعني التي تقوم بها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لدعم الانقلاب
في مصر الاقتصاديه هذا كلام منصور واعتقد
على وسائل الاعلام على الانترنت ممكن اه
ان يرجعوا اليها انا خليني ارجع لي حضرتك
معلومه ثانيه اول حاجه خبر يمكن اول مره
وزي ما قلت لحضرتك انه طلب من الرئيس مرسي
ان يذهب الى اسرائيل وان يوقع ويلتقي ب
مسؤول اسرائيلي خارج اسرائيل اه قراءه او
التناقش حول اتفاق كامب ديفيد في محاوله
هو قراءه ساعتها الرئيس مرسي انه لاستدراج
حتى تقتله الصور مع الاسرائيليين
وتاتي عليه السياسيين انما هناك معلومه
اخرى انه حدث اه وهذا اخبار الرئيس موسى
شخصيا اه انه اتصال بين اه الرئيس اوباما
وبين موسى وقال له اه يعني اه كان ايام
الحوار الوطني مع جبهه الانقاذ وكان
امتناع جبهه الانقاذ عن حضور الحضور
الوطني فقال له يعني اذا يعني ترتب مقابله
مع الناس في ايران في اسرائيل او بعض
الاشخاص فيهم لم يسمي الرئيس الشخص الذي
يعني سماه الرئيس اوباما وانه ما استطيع
ان يقنع اثنين من قاده جبهه الانقاذ سماهم
للرئيس مرسي و اتحفظ على ذكر اسمائهم انه
يعني يحضروا الحوار يعني قالوا احنا
نستطيع وانا عبر تكلم تكلم يعني اه السيد
فلان والسيد فلان اه بحضور الاجتماعات
لانهم يعتبرون بامريكا انا ب انا ب لحضرتك
حوار اه يعني قالوا للرئيس محمد مرسي
ليس هناك شك في ذلك ولكن انا بقول لحضرتك
انه اوامر
ما حدث من انقلاب عسكري والمغالاه في اه
اه اه السياسيه التي كانت ضد الرئيس كانت
ليس ببعيد عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وليس بعيدا عن القوى الاقليميه التي تريد
ان تعيد العسكر ونظام دوله مبارك
السلطانيه عن الحكم اما الحديث على انه
نحنا نقول انه ال المشروع الاسلامي
السياسي فشل وكذا فاستدلال هذا غير صحيح
يعني انا المشاهدين الى التجربه التركيه
نعم فشل اربكان ولكن نجح اردوغان وبعد كده
ما تعلم سياسيه المسائل الديمقراطيه تحتاج
الى المزيد من التعامل مزيد من الوقت حتى
يكون هناك مشروع سياسي حقيقي
يرتكز الى يعني قيم اسلاميه وليس بالضروره
يعني اه اه
عموميه اه وهذه القيام اه تقود في الاخر
الى مشروع السياسه حقيقه وضع الحديث يعني
هناك
يعني تجربه النهضه في تونس نجحت واعتقد
انه المسار الديمقراطي بصفه عامه مشروع
بديل الان مكتمل الاركان
اه فكره ال مع المقاومه ضد الاحتلال
السياسيه
وايضا عندما
الاسد قال ايضا هذا دليل على
اعاده النظر في العلاقات المصريه
الاسرائيليه في معاهده السلام كانت مطروحه
بعد ثوره
باعتقادي مطروحه الفكره ممكن
اه هذا يتوقف على مسار الامور في في مصر
ال اه اعاده
التفاوض حول كامب ديفيد يتوقف على نوع
الحكم الذي سياتي عند تنفيذ خريطه الطريق
ويتوقف على مدى الحراك الشعبي في مصر
ومدى اتفاقه او عدم اتفاقه مع بنود هذه
المعاهده النقطه الثانيه انه من الناحيه
العمليه
سيصعب جدا اه تغيير معاهده السلام
المصريه الاسرائيليه تغييرا جذريا
ولكن من الممكن بالتاكيد لو صارت الثوره
المصريه في مسارها الصحيح بمعنى التعبير
عن الاراده الشعبيه المصريه الواعيه من
الممكن جدا التفاوض حول عدد من شروط هذه
المعاهده واهم ما يجب التفاوض عليه باي
شكل من الاشكال
هو التفاوض مع اسرائيل على ما يحدث في
الحبشه لان من المعروف ان اسرائيل
وخبرائها ودعاياتها وراء محاولات
تقليل امدادات المياه من النيل الى مصر
وهذا في واقع الامر هو انتهاك صريح
وصارخ لمعاهده السلام بين مصر واسرائيل
اه اختم ب نقطه اخيره بالنسبه للكلام اللي
قاله الاخ حاتم عزام انا كنت برد على كلمه
بنا قوات الضغط اسرائيل تضغط على امريكا
من اجل تاييد الحكم العسكري كل ما قاله هو
عباره عن العمليات اغواء وغرائب مساعدات
الحكم العسكري العسكريه وليس ضغطا بالمعنى
السليم وشكرا
السماح اسرائيل ام
يعني هنا في معاهده السلام السماح بدخول
الجيش المصري الجنود المصريين
في سيناء
لمحاربه ما يسمونه الارهاب وايضا ما يجري
بالنسبه لل انفاق مع غزه
اذا ما يؤشر ذلك في العلاقه الحاليه بين
اسرائيل والقاهره
اه طبعا هناك تنسيق طبعا اليوم في اه اه
اشياء جديده اه
الجهاديين والمنظمات الجهاديه في سيناء اه
اه اه
تحديدا و اه تهدد امن اسرائيل وكمان تهدد
عن
ولذلك في هناك مصلحه مشتركه في تلك
المصادر مصريه
علاقاته وتنسيق ما بين حماس وهذه المنظمات
الجهاديه او بعض من المنظمات الجهاديه اه
قياداتها موجوده داخل قطاع غزه واه اه
علاقات حماس والاخوان وهناك اه مسلحه
مشتركه اخرى بين اسرائيل والسلطات المصريه
وبالاضافه الى ذلك م ديفيد اه اه
التوقيع عليه قبل ثلاثين او خمسه
وثلاثين
سنه
اه اه مثل اه كانت اه اه
التعاون المصري لعمليه السلام والاتفاق
السلام كان كامل واه بدون اي
مشاكل ولذلك اعتقد بان اه الكثيرون في
اسرائيل يعتقدون في انا في مجال لبحث
ملفات
واه لبحث موضوع ده مركز الجيش المصري في
اه اه
اه انا لا اعتقد بان اخذ هذا اليوم والجيش
المصري
مصدر تهديد ال اه اه اسرائيل طبعا هناك
مشاكل طبعا المشكله الفلسطينيه بدون تسويه
المشكله الفلسطينيه لا مستقبلي لل كانت
اللي
عربيه ولكن
كامل على ما قاله الضيف من القدس عن انها
لم يعودوا في الجندي المصري اي عدو الى اي
حد اه يشتركان في المصلحه بما يجري في
سيناء وفي غزه ايضا
اه ولا الاسرائيلي في اي جندي عربي اي عدو
لها باي شكل من الاشكال في الوقت الحالي
وسواء كان هذا او ذاك فاسرائيل لا تزال
ترفض بتفوق عسكريين كبير على كافه الجيوش
العربيه وبالتالي فهي لا ترى فيها اه
ثانيا ان الحصر الكلام عن التفاوض او
اعاده التفاوض في معاهده السلام بين مصر
واسرائيل في موضوع سيناء وموضوع اه
مقاومه ما يسمى بالارهاب وما الى ذلك هذا
سوف يكون خطرا استراتيجيا كبيرا من جانب
الاداره المسؤوليه ايا كانت لما يجب ان ي
يشمل ذلك موضوع الحبشه وموضوع النيل وكثير
موعد من المواضيع الاخرى لم يعد يعني في
الجيوش العربيه كما قال ان العدو يعني
اتفاهم تحت سلطه الانقلاب العسكري اه اللي
ال ال السياسه اسرائيل قالت احنا انتقل
يعني كانوا يقول على مبارك الكنز
الاستراتيجي الان يقولون على السيسي البطل
القومي انما انا اعتقد انه اه ال ال
الثورات العربيه والربيع العربي اه اه
سيتم مشروع انشاء الله لانه هذا يهدف الى
تحقيق الاستقلال الوطني الحقيقي والاراده
الوطنيه وهو يرى في مجمله اما القضيه
الفلسطينيه في القلب من هذا
كامل ومن القدس
و اشكر متابعتكم مشاهدينا الكرام اذن بهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
ام
[موسيقى]